[Music]
stop-motion animated movies have been
around a long time but there's a
Hollywood studio solely dedicated to
bringing the animation style into the
21st century
Leica Studios is responsible for movies
like Coraline ParaNorman Kubo and the
two strings and most recently missing
link creating each movie is more
painstaking than the last for the
oscar-nominated studio with missing link
being its most ambitious to date
[Music]
I think for me stop-motion is is truly
special because it has a unique quality
to it that almost go it speaks to your
childhood when you're a kid and you're
playing with toys and you're imagining
them come to life this is Chris Butler
he's the movies writer and director he
decided to direct missing link in the
vein of Raiders of the Lost Ark and
around the world in 80 days and it was
an idea 15 years in the making
but first a little background the first
stop-motion animation film is thought to
be 1898 the Humpty Dumpty circus it's a
painstaking process in which objects are
moved in small increments frame by frame
and though it's difficult it stood the
test of time and few places are doing it
better right now than Leica which was
first founded in 2005 and continues to
push the envelope while remaining true
to stop-motion roots take for example
its use of rigging systems as seen on
this horse puppet the rig doesn't help
move the puppet but rather enables
animators to manipulate it this is
helpful for puppets of unusual shapes
and sizes and thus allows the animators
to dream big it also came in handy for
some of the movies action scenes like
one that takes place on a collapsing ice
bridge if you think about a character
jumping while its feet are on the ground
you you can manipulate that puppet but
what do you do for the frames when its
feet are off the ground
it can't mysteriously float so you have
a rig attached to it that will support
its weight even with the support system
this sequence was so complicated that it
took about a year to shoot even when I
was writing that I thought I shouldn't
be writing this Butler wanted the action
to feel like something you might see in
a live action movie in missing link Hugh
Jackman placed Sir Lionel Frost an
adventurer who discovers the missing
link known to some as Bigfoot or
Sasquatch voiced by Zach Galifianakis
well that didn't go as planned Frost is
given an unlikely task helping unite
link with his long-lost ancestors
missing link is the first Leica
production in which all the main
protagonists are adults and it greatly
shaped how the movie was designed you
based the scale of the movie around the
size of your main character so it's not
the puppets themselves that need to be
bigger but what they interact with needs
to be smaller there is an optimal size
for a puppet it's around about 12 13
inches that's a good size if you get
bigger than that then the poor animator
has to wrestle with it if you get
smaller than that then you can't get the
amount of mechanics into the actual
puppet that you require so that's a good
size Sir Lionel Frost hit the sweet spot
at about 13 inches tall link meanwhile
stood at about 16 inches tall the sets a
missing link
Butler estimated we're about two-thirds
the size of those on Kubo which meant
they could fit more sets into one
building which is very useful for a
movie that had such a wide array of
locations including forests mountains
and the open ocean but you wouldn't call
any of these constructions tiny at all
think the hardest character on missing
link was probably link himself he's
certainly the most complicated puppet
that we've ever had at the studio I
think he took over a year to figure out
and really it's it's it's because he's
covered in half head to toe and it
doesn't help that he is the shape of an
avocado he doesn't have a neck he's
basically a big cuddly lump fur might be
the most difficult part of the design of
a given claymation character but learn
the missing link team found a way around
this they didn't cover linked in actual
hair I think because of the stylization
of this movie we decided that link
should his hair should look the same as
the hair on the heads of the characters
so we went for this very you know
intricate sculpted tufting which was
hand sculpted in clay and then cast and
eventually he became a silicon puppet
the world the characters are given to
inhabit is truly amazing the crew bill a
moving train and an accompanying track
for it
a sequence set inside a stagecoach was
powered by motors and rumble seats yet
this famously practical medium isn't CGI
free the Loch Ness monster who pops up
early in the movie required CG animation
for most of its massive body the head
and neck are practical but a lot of what
you see underwater had to be computer
animated this is just one of the ways in
which stop-motion which has been around
practically since the start of movies
stays modern without abandoning what
makes it so special I think as long as
there are artists out there who love and
respect the medium of stop-motion there
will continue to be stories told I don't
think it will ever really go away it
just requires people to champion it
certainly it like we love it we look the
look of it we love to feel a bit
we love the artistry of it and I think
as long as you you can still move with
the times you can still use technology
to help but you can embrace stop-motion
but for what's special about it in the
end for me what that means is it's real
lights on real objects and there is
something about the imperfection of
reality that is magical
[Music]
you